c'est l'heure tout de suite de notre
seconde et va dans ce sens public vous
savez il est volontairement décalée de
l'actualité
du jour ce soir je pourrait plutôt dire
qu'il est d'actualité lors de chaque
élection présidentielle puisqu'on va
parler des parrainages 500 signatures
d'élus pour pouvoir concourir faut-il
réformer ce système très français avant
de confronter les arguments de mes
invités les détails et les explications
de flora sauvage
c'est le sésame pour être candidat à la
présidentielle il faut rassembler 500
signatures d'élus répartis sur au moins
trente départements différents mais une
loi de 2016 à supprimer l'anonymat des
parrainages une transparence que
dénoncent certains candidats il y a eu
une perversion de la loi originel par
françois hollande dans le mandat
précédent
en rendant publics les noms des maires
c'est un scandale démocratique à cette
semaine de la date limite de dépôt des
parrainages auprès du conseil
constitutionnel
eric zemmour comme marine le pen tire à
boulet rouge sur le système actuel
plutôt que de rendre les parrainages
anonyme ce qui ne changerait rien sur le
plan démocratique mais éviterait
précisément que certains utilisent les
parrainages pour faire pression sur les
uns ou sur les autres et bien les
gouvernements successifs laisse filer de
son côté jean luc mélenchon de la france
insoumise a sollicité gérard larcher
pour que le président du sénat rappelle
la règle aux élus le parrainage ne
signifie pas le soutien nous pouvons à
très court terme aussi facilité tout ça
en rétablissant l'anonymat des
parrainages mais le gouvernement estime
qu'il est trop tard pour changer les
règles il ya des règles du jeu on change
pas les règles me semble-t-il à quelques
jours du match à chaque fois on nous dit
qu'ils n'auront pas leur signature c'est
une façon de faire parler de soi le sans
doute montrer parfois un peu de
persécution pour rappel à la dernière
présidentielle
la fin de l'anonymat des parrainages
n'avait pas entraîné une chute drastique
du nombre de signatures ni même de
candidats ce système est il à bout de
souffle voilà le thème le titre d'autres
débats j'accueille patrick kanner
bonsoir bonsoir et âme du sénateur du
nord présents les groupes socialistes
écologistes et républicains au sénat
anne-charlotte bezina vent soir parce
que
constitutionnaliste maître de
conférences en droit public benjamin
morel bonsoir maître de conférences en
droit public à l'université paris 2
panthéon assas
j'accueille également avec nous
aujourd'hui plex en visioconférence
sébastien chenu qui est député et reines
du nord rassemblement national porte
parole de marine le pen et bonsoir à
vous et jean jacques urvoas bonsoy
ancien garde des sceaux vous êtes à
l'origine de la loi du 25 avril 2016 qui
a mis fin à l'anonymat des parrainages
qui est pas exactement d'ailleurs on est
on détaillera tout ça tout à l'heure
c'est plus subtil que ça matthieu
croissandeau est toujours à mes côtés
évidemment faut-il réformer je veux bien
avoir votre point de vue aux uns et aux
autres le système actuel patrick camair
pourquoi pas
j'ai lu avec attention la tribune de mon
ancien collègue au gouvernement jean
jacques urvoas que je salue
particulièrement je dis pourquoi pas
parce que finalement même si la loi est
dur c'est la loi il faut l'appliquer
mais au regard de l'évolution des
demandes on regarde l'évolution de la
société on pourrait imaginer un système
mixte et j'y reviendrai tout malheur si
vous le souhaitez qui nous avons déjà
porté le groupe socialiste plus j'ai
l'honneur de présider au sénat dans le
cadre d'une loi organique avait déposé
un amendement pour imaginer un système
mixte et on détaillera tout à l'heure à
un certain ben zina qui souffrent c'est
indispensable réforme au pourquoi pas
moi je je je proposerai le pourquoi
d'autres c'est cela la vraie question
c'est si on réforme et il faut réformer
pour quelque chose de mieux et à l'heure
actuelle est ce que ce système des
parrainages est vraiment à bout de
souffle est ce qu'il a montré ses
limites alors c'est vrai que
politiquement on entend beaucoup de
récusation en disant qu'il ya donc une
forme de pression qui s'exerce et
finalement une inadéquation avec le
mouvement démocratique mais mais c'est
pas toujours certain que ce soit
complètement avéré parce que en effet il
faut le dire c'est pas du tout la
première élection où on entende parler
de ça ça existe depuis 68 88 depuis 80
ans on a des candidats qui nous disent
on n'y arrive pas et qui finalement y
arrive donc est-ce que ça n'est pas
aussi un petit peu une partie du jeu de
dire eh bien on va se présenter devant
les élus on va essayer d'obtenir leur
lors leur assentiment finalement et
rappelons aussi que le parrainage n'est
pas un soutien simplement juste une
démonstration de voile à de sérieux donc
on a besoin de ce filtre quel autre fils
peut-on trouver c'est vraiment ça la
grande question je précise benjamin
morel vous en pensez quoi est-ce qu'il
est encore adapté à notre société 2022
ce sera une affaire de société c est qu
un anachronisme un anachronisme par
rapport à l'état politique du pays au
moment où il a été inventé l'idée de ce
filtre en réalité c'est d'éviter des
candidatures extrêmement minoritaire
ubuesque etc or dans les années 60 c'est
assez facile parce que un candidat qui
veut réellement arrivé au pouvoir qui a
une chance d'arriver au pouvoir fait
généralement partie d'un grand parti
politique qui a un ancrage local et donc
pour qui c'est une formalité aujourd'hui
si vous prenez les candidats les mieux
placés dans cette élection valérie
pécresse a en effet un parti bien
implanté mais sinon emmanuel macron eric
zemmour marine le pen jean-luc mélenchon
tous ont des difficultés parce que les
partis ne sont pas implantées vous avez
eu peur du logo entre champ politique
évidemment pas être d'algos vous entre
le champ politique national d'un côté et
le champ politique locale aujourd'hui
vous avez une vraie différence et donc
ça crée des tensions par ailleurs
l'argument de dire tout le monde y est
arrivé jusqu'à présent m'apparaît assez
dangereux pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que c'est passé près pour parle
par exemple jean marie le pen en 2002
ensuite l'argent que vous mettez en tant
que candidat pour aller chercher les
signatures pour aller démarcher les
maires le temps que vos militants m
c'est du temps et de l'argent que vous
mettez pas dans la campagne est donc
sacré un handicap de base pour certains
partis pour certains candidats qui ne se
justifie pas aucun impératif on y
revient à voir évidemment matthieu
croissandeau vous pensez que l'anonymat
c'est un faux débat pourquoi oui parce
que c'est quand même très étonnant qu'à
un moment où l'ère de la transparence
règne on demande des comptes aux élus
sur la façon dont ils prennent leurs
décisions sur leur patrimoine sur leur
train de vie parfois même sur leur
chambre à coucher et ben voilà un sujet
où on leur demanderait pas de compte
alors qu'il s'agit de l'élection
principal de notre pays c'est là la
magistrature suprême pardon et que les
parrainages pour être accordée par des
élus anonyme moi ça me paraît aberrant
on nous dit la loi aurait changé alors
on y reviendra avec jean jacques urvoas
se sent tellement ce qui est à la fois
vrai et faux parce que le conseil
constitutionnel auparavant tiré au sort
sans oublier les noms de 500 dont il
ressort mais quand vous étiez un petit
candidat c'était la quasi-intégralité de
vos noms étaient publiés on nous dit que
certains candidats auraient du mal à
récolter leurs parrainages parce que les
élus n'ose pas s'afficher avec eux mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est mr
aurait honte vis-à-vis de leurs
électeurs d'afficher leur soutien pour
tel ou tel candidat peut-être que les
dix candidats seraient mieux inspirés de
se mettre à réfléchir sur ce qui peut
faire honte à ces élus dans leurs
discours dans leurs idées dans la
proposition de leur comportement à ce
point pour que des élus refusent de lait
par année comme par hasard on marque ce
qui ont souvent le plus de soucis sont
des candidats les plus extrêmes qui
tiennent pas des discours majoritaire ou
consensuelle bien évidemment mais des
discours les plus radicaux ou les plus
anti système certains candidats
dénoncent aussi un système verrouillé
pour faire barrage au candidat
antisystème c'est la formule
on en parle et moi je considère que ça
n'a jamais empêché des candidat
antisystème de se présenter prenez lutte
ouvrière des trotskistes ils sont là
depuis des scrutins prenez le npa
nouveau parti anticapitaliste trotskiste
aussi sont là depuis très très longtemps
on nous dit que ces parrainages ferait
la part belle aux partis qui sont
implantées ça c'est vrai enfin qu'est ce
qui empêche les autres de s'implanter
est ce qu'empêche jean luc mélenchon et
safran sera soumise aux lieux d'enjamber
les scrutins intermédiaires d'abstention
régionaux à rouen une élection
intermédiaire j'entends bien mais quand
un parti de lui-même décide d'enjamber
les élections intermédiaires disons que
la seule qui compte au fond c'est la
présidentielle eh ben ça pause s'impose
aussi ça pose aussi question qui les
empêche de tisser patiemment un résultat
un réseau d'élus locaux au problème
c'est que d'en dessous dans les scrutins
locaux vous êtes obligé de vous allier
or c'est souvent des formations
politiques qui refusent par nature
l'alliance puisque elles sont radicales
antisystème et qu'elles veulent
retourner la table enfin on eu ce
système conditi verrouillé n'a jamais
empêché de petits candidats opiniâtre
parfois sans parti d'y arriver on peut
citer jean lassalle la dernière françois
asselineau je pense à jacques cheminade
qui chaque cheminot n'y arrive qu'est ce
qui ferait que marine le pen ou jean luc
mélenchon n'y arriverai pas j'y reste le
problème c'est que jacques machut menad
c'est vrai il a ratissé il a tiré les
sonnettes il est allé voir les élus et
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait pendant cinq
ans il sait qu'ils ont fait pendant cinq
ans je vais vous redonner à présent
temps de sébastien chenu tout de suite
parce que finalement d'une certaine
façon sébastien chenu et matthieu
croissandeau dit balayé un peu devant
votre porte quoi qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça
non mais qui infiltrent d'abord pour
l'élection présidentielle ça semble tout
à fait normale et je crois que la
philosophie qui a présidé à cette idée a
du sens saint vith des candidats dits
folklorique c'était pour ça donc ça y'a
pas de soucis maintenant je pense que
d'ailleurs mathieu croissandeau fait une
erreur terrible de lecture ça montre
qu'il ne connaît pas le terrain qui
n'est jamais allé chercher des
parrainages que moi j'y suis allé encore
cette semaine les maires ne vous disent
pas qu'ils aient honte de parrainer un
candidat et que leurs habitants vont les
mettre à la mangue notamment dans des
communes où par exemple moi je vois
marine le pen parfois que les 60% dans
des petites communes rurales le maire me
dit mais moi tout le conseil municipal
vote marine le pen c'est pas ça c'est le
président de l'agglo qui fait partie de
ce système et qui est très politisée et
qui lui fait comprendre et en étant en
ce moment dans les périodes de
budgétaire et qui lui dit grosso modo si
vous aventurer à parrainer des candidats
qui vont qui n'ont pas mes options
politiques qui peut faire de l'ombre
bien et bien attention on va décaler
d'une année peut-être la subvention pour
votre équipement on gère ça c'est la
réalité les maires vous le dise ou alors
bien sûr ils le disent pas publiquement
il on a suffisamment d'ennuis pour ne
pas en plus en avoir est à présent
dénommée mais il vous est jamais ils
vous disent moi j'ai des mères qui m'ont
dit très concrètement si ce n'était pas
anonyme je vous donnerai mon parrainage
ça ne me poserait aucun problème pardon
de vous interrompre mais est-ce que vous
avez des preuves des noms à nous donner
d'élus qui ont subi ces précieux parce
que quand vous apportez que marine le
pen porte également mais voilà on
aimerait bien pouvoir vérifier tout ça
d'abord on n'est pas dans un tribunal
jeu peu avant 69 m il faut complètement
naïf enfin je veux dire tous les gens
qui sont autour de cette table sont ou
des observateurs ou des acteurs de la
vie politique et il sait comment ça se
passe personne n'est naïf vous avez des
présidents d'agglo je dis pas tous il ya
des gens qui se comportent bien dans la
vie tu sais pas le problème mais il ya
des présidents d'agglo et ses vannes oc
de tous les côtés qui font pression sur
les candidats si tu parraine un candidat
de gauche qui est en train de faire de
l'ombre aux miens et qui va empêcher la
qualification du bien un site du paren
le pen si tu parlais de mélenchon et
acceptera écoute tu l'as semer la
zizanie tu as politiser la gnose que
aussi des agglos dans lequel on dit ici
on fait pas de politique s'il te plaît
tout ça c'est la réalité c'est pas c'est
pas un fantasme et puis vous avez un des
maires qui vous disent écoutez nous on a
suffisamment d'ennui on ne veut plus
parler des personnes c'est encore un
autre versant dans sort de j'allais dire
la sensibilité politique on ne veut plus
parler personne parce que notre nom est
affiché on est insultée on est traîné
dans la boue sur les réseaux sociaux on
a suffisamment d'ennui trouver une autre
solution mais nous on ne peut plus
parler des personnes or le parrainage
des mères c'est une prérogative
finalement qu'on donne au maire c'est
pas un pouvoir c'est une responsabilité
finalement supplémentaires et certains
maires alors le plus assumer cette
responsabilité bien entendu c'est vous
redonner la parole est évidemment vous
êtes avec nous pour toute la durée du
débat c'est bercy a tenu mais je
voudrais maintenant entendre jean
jacques urvoas qui ne s'est pas encore
exprimé je rappelle que vous êtes à
l'origine de cette loi 25 avril 2016
alors qu'ils qui ne met pas fin
fondamentalement à
à l'anonymat des parrainages mais qui
transforme le système expliquez nous ce
que vous avez voulu faire
non il ya plusieurs choses qui ont déjà
été dites qu'ils sont assez juste mais
ça a au moins un mérite c'est que ça
nous fait rajeunir parce que la question
de la publicité elle n'existait pas il
ya cinq ans elles n'existaient pas il ya
dix ans elle n'existait pas il ya quinze
ans et il y avait exactement la même
séquence de candidats qui se
présentaient comme étant des victimes je
me souviens par exemple qu'en 2002 jean
marie le pen s'était mis en situation
téléphonant à des mères pour obtenir des
parrainages et à l'époque c'était pas la
question de la publicité le parrainage
est inaccessible et vous avez très
justement rappelé que depuis qu'il
l'avait existe 500 c'est à dire depuis
1976 aucun candidat n'a jamais eu de
difficulté à franchir la barre
d'ailleurs pour s'en rendre compte il
suffit de regarder ce que le conseil
constitutionnel publie tous les cinq ans
quand il publie la liste des parrainages
reçu
si vous prenez celle de 2017 au delà de
des onze qui ont été qualifiés les
autres étaient extrêmement éloignée
c'est à dire personne n'est vraiment à
la marge celle qui arrivait juste
derrière c'était rama yade qui avait 383
signature et alain juppé qui n'était pas
candidat et qui en avait obtenu 313 et
mon ancien collègue patrick kanner avait
même reconnu une signature alors qu'à ma
connaissance il n'était pas non plus
candidat qu'est ce que nous avons je
confirme je connais et évidemment avec
ce succès là peut-être que j'aurais pu
aller plus loin mais bon méfiez vous il
ya déjà suffisamment pour être renaître
en ce moment dans l'aveyron avait obtenu
7 donc il y avait un peu plus d'avancé m
qu'est ce que nous avons voulu faire
avec cette droite qui était d'ailleurs
effectivement une proposition de loi que
j'avais écrite est soutenu par le groupe
socialiste et bien tout simplement nous
avons voulu répondre au conseil
constitutionnel qui depuis
1974 élection après élection demandait à
ce que le législateur organique
garantissent la publicité parce que lui
ce qu'il avait comme obligation c'était
de publier 500 signatures donc ils
tiraient au sort et il avait pris sous
son autorité de publier dans les locaux
du conseil constitutionnel la liste de
tous les autres afin de respecter le
principe d'égalité je conclus en vous
posant cette question est-ce qu'il faut
100 la règle du jeu la question c'est
pour quoi faire est ce que l'on peut
considérer comme en 1974 qu'il faut
changer la règle parce qu'il ya trop de
candidats ou est-ce qu'il faut la
changer parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
candidats de mon point de vue il y a
trop de candidats et donc il faudrait
changer la règle mais pour rehausser la
barre comme d'ailleurs d'autres membres
du conseil constitutionnel l'avait déjà
proposé alors justement va se projeter
dans des pistes de réforme et je propose
à audrey bêtasse de nous rejoindre de
nouveau puisque audrey l'an dernier le
sénat avait anticipé une certaine façon
cette question des parrainages oui
c'était en début d'année dernière au
moment de l'examen d'un projet de loi
organique sur l'élection présidentielle
le groupe socialiste votre groupe
monsieur kader avait déposé un
amendement pour réduire à 250 au lieu de
500 le nombre de parrainages d'élus il
envisageait de remplacer ses 250
signatures d'élus en moins donc par 150
mille signatures de citoyens un chiffre
ni négligeable limitatif d'après les
rédacteurs de l'amendement alors
l'objectif c'était de raccrocher les
citoyens à la politique et je vous
propose d'écouter éric kerrouche le
sénateur ps des landes à ce sujet il
nous semble que le système actuel est de
moins en moins légitime aux yeux des
citoyens qui sont écartés de cette phase
de pré qualification au profit des lucky
eux-mêmes subissent un peu trop la
pression de cette compétition de ce fait
il nous paraît justifié que les citoyens
puissent est amené à participer et
ramener pardon à participer à cette à
cette préface de deux sélections alors
ce système mixte rappelle une
proposition de la commission jose pas en
2012 qui avait pour but pour but pardon
d'améliorer la vie politique en france
l'une des mesures phares c'était de
supprimer totalement les 500 signatures
d'élus et de les remplacer par 150
signatures de citoyens vérifié par des
préfets cent cinq mille cent cinquante
mille pardons signature de sites
vérifiés par les préfets lee n'a jamais
vu le jour et au sénat la proposition de
votre groupe n'a pas non plus été
retenus alors l'un des motifs c'était
qu'il est trop facile de frauder en
envoyant un soutien sur papier libre par
exemple merci aux de révolte as pour ses
explications benjamin morel qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de cette idée ce
panachage en quelques semaines je suis
fondamentalement favorable c'est à dire
que il faut il faut se remettre encore
une fois dans l'esprit du constituant
l'objectif c'était quoi à l'origine
l'objectif c'était d'éviter les petites
candidatures qui ne représentait pas
grand chose et en effet vous êtes on est
le seul pays du monde où tous les cinq
ans on peut trancher entre les
trotskistes lambertiste et les trois de
ce qui se publie sts c'est merveilleux
mais ces candidats qui ne font peur à
personne en réalité ils ont pas ils ont
beaucoup moins de mal à trouver leur
signature le vrai problème ce n'est pas
le nombre de candidats faut on a deux
faux débat la peau le premier faux débat
c'est sur la publicité des signatures là
en effet la dernière loi la loi ne se
change pas grand chose le deuxième faux
débat seuil at il trop de candidatures
non n'est pas trop de candidatures et
quand tu y ailles ariès candidat en 2002
pour vous il ya le problème en vain pas
vous parler on va voir les chiffres du
nombre de candidats sur les dernières
problème c'est pas le nombre des
candidatures est le problème c'est la
représentativité des candidatures pour
moi il faut un système de panachage
pourquoi et bien parce qu'en réalité si
vous faites totalement sauter le nombre
de signatures d'élus vous risquez
d'avoir des candidatures on va dire de
fan club acceptera vous trouvez une star
de la télé et puis tout d'un coup ou
trouver 150 personnes c'est pas
difficile où on peut envisager d'avoir
100 250 signatures de maires quelque
chose d'accessible à tout candidat un
peu importants mais le nombre de
signatures de citoyens est également
extrêmement important d'abord parce que
ça ouvre beaucoup plus pour des
candidatures réellement représentative
mais également parce que ça limite
justement des micros candidature
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes le un
candidat d'une toute petite formation
qui va faire 0,00 quelque chose pour
cent mais que vous avez un réseau de mer
vous pouvez vous présenter avoir 150
mille citoyens ce serait beaucoup qu'on
beaucoup plus compliqué avoir un
panachage ça permettrait d'avoir
peut-être candidature et des
candidatures beaucoup plus
représentatives et derrière le moins de
candidatures et plus représentative vous
avez également une organisation du débat
public par la suite qui est beaucoup
plus cohérente beaucoup plus claire et
qui permet bien de repenser par exemple
le temps de parole l'argument de la
fraude que rappelait audrey il tient à
me tiens pas non non je vous donne un
exemple très concret
sur référendum d'initiative partagée que
de remporter contre la privatisation des
aéroports de paris le système qui avait
été mis en place donc le par le ministre
de l'intérieur pour recevoir les
signatures nécessaires la mise en oeuvre
on a obtenu quand même 1 1 million 200
mille ans fallait 4 millions cet été
beaucoup mais un million deux cent mille
signatures c'est quand même pas
négligeable et totalement contrôlé
totalement transparent avec une
vérification par le conseil
constitutionnel donc les moyens
techniques aujourd'hui et heureusement à
sont là pour pour ce faire et nous nous
avons soutenu ce mixte potentiel
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que jean
jacques urvoas hishon est socialiste je
suis socialiste à dire une perruque
socialiste ça vous montre que nous ne
sommes pas arc bouté sur voilà des
choses du passé on essaie de faire
évoluer la démocratie la démocratie
représentative aujourd'hui a besoin
aussi d'une dose de démocratie
participative
la société a changé et la proposition
d'avoir 250 signatures d'élus pas que
des maires dans les quarante deux mille
signatures potentiel il y à des mères
mais aussi des
départementaux des régionaux les élus
vraiment de différentes responsabilités
et les les signatures des citoyens
c'est l'occasion finalement de mettre
une patte démocratique complémentaires
non pas en substitution mais
complémentaires donc ce mixte qui
d'ailleurs est aussi proposée par david
lisnard le président des maires
de france me paraît être une évolution
souhaitable qui règlerait l'ensemble des
difficultés qui ont été évoqués donc oui
à ce mélange permettant finalement une
meilleure reconnaissance des candidats
anne charrier de bezina donc vous dites
oui mais pour faire quoi est ce que par
exemple votre objectif c'est qu'ils
aient moins de candidats ou est-ce qu'au
contraire vous pensez qu'on on est dans
une bonne dans un lot en équilibre alors
il faut savoir quand même qu'en france
on a de toute façon ce système très
particulier d'avoir un président dans un
régime parlementaire qui fait que de
toute façon toutes les points de
comparaison qu'on va prendre avec le
système polonais portugais etc n'ont
aucune commune mesure donc de toutes
façons c'est très difficile de comparer
la france avec un autre régime mais je
crois quand même qu'en terme de panels
de représentativité du nom de petits
candidats on est vraiment pas mal loti
et après je ne suis pas totalement sûr
ce soit un faux débat non plus le nombre
de candidats parce que vous disiez à
propos du temps de parole on le disciple
quand même beaucoup quand on a affaire
beaucoup de candidats et est ce que en
termes de sincérité de clarté du débat
parlementaire qui sont au sol finalement
et du débat électoral qui sont seuls
impératifs constitutionnels est ce qu'on
est vraiment dans les clous quand on en
a autant et est ce que la question de la
représentativité justement c'est pas
aussi celle du poids et moi je crois que
le poids dans la localité ont là en ce
moment on lui fait dire de fausses
choses alors moi ce panachage je pense
qu'il peut être tout à fait réalisable
après
l'exemple du référendum d'initiative
partagée était quand même sur un laps de
temps bien plus long que ce que nous
avons pour les élections présidentielles
je pense notamment à la primaire qui est
en cours là en terme de délais on serait
très très juste pour arriver à obtenir
les parrainages citoyens et pour arriver
à contrôler cela dignement auprès du
conseil dont il ya des questions
d'organisation à mon avis et la question
de la représentativité moi je ne suis
pas sûr que les élus locaux ne puissent
pas aussi joué le rôle à ce niveau là
alors vous parliez avec raison de la
déconnexion du local et de l'homme qui
rencontre le peuple qui fait finalement
toute l'originalité cette présidentielle
mais c'est ensuite des choses qu'on va
reprocher à ces candidats je pense
notamment à emmanuel macron qui a réussi
à émerger difficilement avec les 500
parrainages mais après on lui a dit mais
finalement son parti n'a aucune attache
locale et il n'a remporté aucune
élection intermédiaire donc est ce qu'on
peut vraiment être cet homme qui
rencontre le peuple et ne pas ensuite
subir cette critique d'avoir un manque
d'ancrage local donc l'ancrage local est
ce qu'à un moment donné il ne va pas
devenir nécessaire et moi je ne sais pas
si ça n'est pas reculer pour mieux
sauter finalement sur cette question
sébastien chenu vous en êtes où vous
approcher des 500 est à quoi 450 c'est
ça à peu près je crois qu'on joue pas
qu'on est entre 400 et 450
donc les choses sont pas faites moi je
rejoins c'est benjamin morel lorsqu'il
dit que la question n'est pas le nombre
c'est pas à la loi de fixer le nombre de
candidats aux élections présidentielles
s'il y en a 9 ou 15 et d'ailleurs
finalement on s'aperçoit et qu'il y a eu
depuis 20 ans grosso modo une grosse
dizaine de candidats à l'élection
présidentielle et je pense qu'il y en
aura au final une grosse dizaine la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
effectivement celle de la
représentativité est ce qu'il est normal
que des candidats qui sont à la tête de
mouvements politiques qui présente des
candidats toutes les élections
intermédiaires les régionales les
départementales les législatives les
européennes les sénatoriales ram à ce
point pour pouvoir être présent à
l'élection présidentielle c'est valable
par exemple monsieur mélenchon et pour
madame le pen on voit bien ce sont des
acteurs majeurs de la vie politique il
ne plaisent pas à tout le monde c'est
sûr enfin ce sont des acteurs majeurs il
rassemble des millions de voix et de
l'autre côté il y à des candidats je
pense à la candidature la dernière fois
des modèles macron ou à celle d'eric
zemmour aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont pas
effectivement des candidats qui se le
sont j'ai été habitué des scrutins
intermédiaires mais qui représente à un
moment donné dans l'opinion quelque
chose un courant de pensée une
sensibilité et là aussi on pourrait se
dire c'est pas normal qu'ils soient
privés de l'élection présidentielle dont
il faut trouver un système moi je suis
très ouvert à l'idée que ce système
puisse appuyer sur des parrainages de
français des signatures de français on
pourrait aussi imaginer que les maires
puissent avoir deux options je crois que
david lisnard allait réfléchir aussi à
ça c'est à dire un parrainage dit
républicain et démocratique je parraine
parce que c'est mon boulot de verre de
parler d un candidat et puis une autre
case qui sera un parrainage de soutien
et de coeur je le fais parce que je
soutiens candidats on voit imaginé
plusieurs options mais en tous les cas
je pense que c'est une démocratie mature
qui sont nos vrais de réfléchir à cela
et de faire évoluer ce système il n'ya
pas de loi la loi les fêtes finalement
pour protéger ceux qui ont le plus de
difficulté les plus petits et
aujourd'hui à ceux qui ont plus de
difficultés entre parenthèses les plus
petits ce sont ceux qui ont des partis
politiques qui sont le moins d'élus
locaux sur le terrain il soit vous
pénalisez alors que parfois ils ont plus
de voix lors des élections alors valérie
pécresse a affirmé c'était lundi dernier
sur france info qu' eric zemmour doit
pouvoir se présenter la veille anne
hidalgo elle n'était pas tout à fait du
même avis on écoute la candidate
socialiste la loi qui décide de qui
participe en fonction des parrainages
qui ne les ont pas c'est qu'ils ne
méritent pas d'y participer vous pensez
que ce serait pas un manque pour la
démocratie les gens qui représentent 13
la démocratie elle est définie avant les
sondages par la loi et si la loi dit que
des parrainages doivent être de 500 pour
chacun des candidats sur la ligne de
départ c'est la loi qui doit s'inventer
et la loi c'est la démocratie un plus
haut à we stand qui pour eux ça veut
dire qu'elles n'ont pas convaincu 500
mais patrick kanner vous êtes d'accord
dura lex sed lex mais je dois peut-être
pas dit les mêmes choses en tout cas sur
la même tonalité mais je ne suis pas
candidat la présence d'un public je n'ai
eu qu'à sur le parrainage 2010 est donc
je reste ma place et je puis vous dire
que
quand mon collègue parlementaire
sébastien chenu 10450 grosso modo il
vaut mieux en avoir en promesses de
parrainages 600 ou 700 pour être sûr
d'en avoir cinq sens au bout du bout
parce que la période entre guillemets
entre les promesses de dons et les dons
c'est comme le téléthon il peut y avoir
un décalage entre le début février et
début mars donc pour ce qui nous
concerne je vous rassure nous avons non
seulement le nombre mais bien plus pour
pouvoir faire face à cela non je crois
que aujourd'hui si la loi mais dans ce
que dit la loi dans ce qu'elle gèle goya
c'est quand même un peu gênant qu'elle
dise bah tant pis pour eux alors que
effectivement deux candidats que jarry
présente dans les sondages une large
part de l'opinion amygdales go est
candidate elle rappelle qu'il y à une
loi dans ce cadre là il faut respecter
les conditions la loi actuelle darmana
me chez darmanin a dit très justement on
peut pas changer la loi maintenant
d'ailleurs depuis plusieurs années ce
gouvernement refuse de changer les le
code électoral y compris sur les
modalités de la votation ce que je
regrette parce que on arrive encore une
fois devant un mur avec la crise
sanitaire a qui est toujours
malheureusement présente donc à l'est
d'al gore appelle les règles est là elle
ce matelas potentiellement de signature
c'est un c'est un constat elle n'empêche
pas les autres de l'avoir mais libre et
débrouillez-vous les achats l'un doit
faire preuve de l'action elle empêche un
petit peu parce qu'en réalité où sont
les barrages pour les mères il ya deux
barrages d'abord un barrage politique
quand vous êtes un maire un quartier
dans un parti politique le parti
généralement vous dit tu ne donnera pas
ta candidature à un autre candidat que
moi et donc vous avez des candidats qui
partent avec 5000 signatures d'autres
qui est bien ont des difficultés si vous
allez voir un maire ait l'air excellent
caribou ja oui mais le parti m'a dit non
première complexité deuxième complexité
qui a été évoqué mais qu'importante si
vous êtes dans une interview si vous
êtes dans une agglo même la région
département on va vous dire et là on a
des communautés même si vous êtes non
inscrit qui sont politiques on va vous
dire oui mais en réalité tu ne vas pas
donner ton parrainage ça va être
compliqué nous donc ça c'est un barrage
problématique ensuite il ya une question
d'égalité encore une fois ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie à certains partis
d'aller chercher signature est-ce que
vous accepteriez de faire un sprint avec
un boulet au pied en disant tout est
égal c'est ce qui se passe en revanche
anne hidalgo elle elle fait le sprint
pour le coup mais avec un réacteur
derrière et donc à partir de là
évidemment que c'est beaucoup plus
facile si vous n'avez pas ce problème
des parrainages et bien vous partez avec
une petite longueur d'avancé ça ne fait
pas tout mais ça fait quelque chose en
termes financiers en termes d'énergie je
pense que justement le grand mal qu'on
peut pointer c'est celui de cette idée
de marchandage ou cette idée de pression
de l'un vers l'autre ceux qui ne jouent
pas le jeu finalement c'est ni le
législateur ni le conseil
constitutionnel ni la question de la
publicité ou des petits et des grands
partis c'est les partis eux-mêmes
puisque je suis assez content d'ailleurs
cette idée proposée par david lisnard
qu'on puisse avoir un parent âge
affectif et un parrainage républicain
parce que le parrainage est censé être
républicains par essence donc c'est
vraiment mal comprendre sa nature que de
séparer les deux donc il faut faire
attention à ça des partis politiques
doivent dire qu'il n'ya aucun enjeu
aucune association aux dotations né dans
un contexte drastique de diminution des
aides et des ressources locales il faut
évidemment rappelé que le jeu
démocratique c'est avant tout de se dire
et bien que le meilleur gagne et c'est
quelque chose que des partis dits
politiquement aujourd'hui beaucoup de
mal à rappeler que je serai à bondir sur
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure sur
le finalement ce que ça coûte en temps
et en argent aux candidats qui ont du
mal à regrouper les parrainages jean
jacques urvoas et c'est quand même une
prime effectivement au parti
gouvernement historique
et écouter alors regardons la réalité j
parce que moi j'entends beaucoup de gens
qui se plaignent mais tout le monde aura
ces signatures tout simplement parce que
tout le monde a toujours eu mais ces
signatures et et moi je trouve qu
effectivement quand vous avez sur les
trois dernières élections 33 candidats
dont 15 au final n'obtiennent que 2% -2
2% des voix
franchement guy carcassonne dans une
configuration identique parler de
pullulement de présence marginale je
crois qu'il avait raison ensuite les 47
mille signatures parce que je lis
partout qu'il y aurait 42 milles par le
conseil constitutionnel en 2017 a
annoncé 47 mais de signature un
potentiel fort dans ses 47 mille
signatures il y en a cinquante sept pour
cent qui sont issus de mères de moi
mille habitants que l'on n'arrive pas à
convaincre
1,06 pour cent de ce corps électoral ne
me paraît pas annoncer à un gros succès
dans la compétition décisive donc moi je
ne suis pas choqué que on a des efforts
à faire après tout les candidats qui
étaient qui sont devant les électeurs
pour la présentielle rien ne l'empêché
d'avoir des candidats aux élections
municipales aux élections
départementales aux élections c'est pas
un décret divin qui a privé ses
candidats d'élus locaux en capacité
d'appuyer leur candidature au moment
décisif
votre réponse est ce que vous êtes
finalement le ce que je dis là ce que
j'entends un peu en filigrane c'est que
vous êtes dans une stratégie de
victimisation un peu comme à chaque
élection présidentielle
comme écoutez moi je ne comprends pas
bien le lien qu'ils puissent être chez
entre le nombre de parrains les nombre
de signatures de même et le résultat aux
élections présidentielles par exemple
anne hidalgo vous l'avais dit à beaucoup
de paroles mais visiblement dans les
sondages je sais pas la gloire en ce
moment c'est on est à 3 % je crois dans
le sondages d'aujourd'hui donc on peut
pas faire le lien alors qu'elle a
beaucoup peint donc le il n'y a pas de
lien je ne comprends pas comment on peut
faire ce lien de l'autre côté c'est pas
une histoire de victimisation c'est que
on perd beaucoup de temps à chercher ce
type de signature la convaincre des
maires de vous les donner et que pendant
ce temps là on ferait mieux de débattre
les un argument contre argument faire
une campagne d'idées qu'il est exposé
devant les français les chemins qu'on
propose pour notre pays et pas
simplement courir le pays à chercher les
précieux sésames parce que les la
difficulté qui a été qui a été installé
avec 7 cet anonymat et et bien cette
absence d'un animal est bien est une
difficulté supplémentaire
donc voila moi je crois que le temps il
doit être utile pour débattre devant les
français et que je ne vois pas quels
sont les obstacles aujourd'hui ainsi de
faire évoluer la loi ne le corps
électoral il est en mouvement les
sensibilités politiques de notre pays
aujourd'hui ne sont plus les mêmes qu'il
ya un certain nombre d'années ne sont
pas les mêmes d'ailleurs non plus à
chaque élection on peut avoir beaucoup
plus d'élus locaux et on le voit dans
notre pays issus de l'entrevue mais
vieux partis politiques etc les vieux
partis politiques ne récolte pas
forcément l'adhésion des français
lorsqu'ils sont candidats aux élections
présidentielles or avec ce raisonnement
est bien on aurait plus qu effectivement
elle vitam aeternam les républicains il
parti socialiste en duel parce que ce
sont les partis qui ont le plus d'élus
locaux et pourtant ce sens ce qu'ils
font a priori peut-être le moins de voix
aux élections présidentielles on l'a vu
lors des dernières présidentielles
puisque aucun des deux n'était qualifier
au second tour oui y'a pas de lien ce
qui est important c'est d'oxygène et de
démocratie se permettre à chacun de
s'exprimer quand j'entends madame
hidalgo c'est un peu mesquin sincèrement
enfin je veux dire on comprend bien que
l aile et pour que la loi évolue dans
tous les domaines domaines de la société
du sociétal et c'est dans tous les
domaines mais alors pas celui ci parce
que ça peut lui poser problème ou parce
que la démocratie pour aller à la limite
c'est celle de le candidat qui ne
partagent pas cette option banon la
démocratie elle est faite pour vivre et
proxy gêné c'est ça la démocratie mature
oui mais c'est trop tard
c'est trop tard ça je pense que ce
discours peut-être que les luc mélenchon
ou marine le pen aurait dû la voir il ya
un an alors arriver vraiment été emballé
là c'est trop tard ceux qui ont les clés
pour que ça se passe bien ce sont les
grands partis si demain le ps et lr 10
mois là tous les candidats au dessus de
10% dans les enquêtes d'opinion dans une
majorité de enquêtes d'opinion on leur
donne les signatures à ce moment là on a
plus de problème de signature pour cette
élection ensuite il faut que tous les
candidats s'engagent à modifier la loi
parle par d'ailleurs parce que si on
considère que c'est donner aux sondages
on le rappelle dans sa phase est un
succès sans pour qui il va voter
vous vous doutez bien que avec tout le
respect que je dois à jean lassalle que
ses chances d'atteindre le second tour
sont limités il va peut-être m'en
vouloir beaucoup mais j'en ai le
sentiment profond si vous voulez là j'ai
signé turbie bout vous avez mais il a
signé joffé cement mais pour un eric
zemmour pour un jean luc mélenchon quoi
qu'on pense de leur programme vous avez
un courant qui représentative dans
l'opinion on peut juger que les idées
sont mauvaises qu'importe on a un
courant qui est représentatif il est
normal qu'il puisse y avoir un bulletin
eric zemmour qu'il puisse avoir un
bulletin jean luc mélenchon ou alors les
parties qu'il représente sont pas du
tout républicain on les interdit mais si
jamais on les interdit pas il est normal
qu'ils concourent s'il concours les
grands partis s'honorerait à dire pour
ces élections là on accepte de on pousse
nos élus à donner leur signature allez
on s'engage sait jamais on est élu
ensuite à modifier cette loi alors pour
ce convoi a posé après je l'aimerais
lazio mais pourquoi ne faites-vous pas
non non réponse à monsieur chenu mais
madame hidalgo n'a aucunement dit
qu'elle n'était pas prête à voir où elle
évolue elle dit la loi actuelle c'est
celle là est donc on l'appliqué point
barre donc et chacun à vay élargit sa
base mais je ne doute pas je ne doute
pas que mes cheveux tenus continuera à
faire sa tournée comme il le fait
habituellement dans le nord et je le
connais pour aller chercher les
signatures dont je ne sais pas si c'est
une période de victimisation pour
l'extrême droite française mais voilà
moi je souhaite que madame le pen puis
je comptais en respectant le droit je
voudrais bien que vous répondiez à 20
mois elle est ce que finalement les
grands partis ne sonnerait pas faire ce
geste mais aujourd'hui vous avez écouté
et réécouté eric et rouge on apportait
un amendement il y a maintenant un an et
demi pour faire bouger la loi ne nous a
pas échappé qu'il n'était pas
majoritaire au sénat ça reviendra
peut-être un jour mais pas immédiatement
si j'ai bien compris donc oui moi je
suis favorable à ce que la loi évolue je
suis non pas en divergence avec mon ami
jean jacques urvoas mais c'est vrai
qu'il lui est plutôt sur une logique de
mes 500 s'est passé il faut aller un peu
plus loin moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui
les citoyens si on veut les intéressés à
une élection doivent pouvoir participer
y compris en amont de cette élection par
des signatures dûment avalisée et je
crois que ce serait le bon sens
aujourd'hui à une certaine business qui
se passe c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une sorte de culpabilisation des
mères aussi c'est ce que c'est un
discours qu'on entend une sorte de
pression qui pèse notamment d'ailleurs
beaucoup sur les maires sans étiquette
on peut dire que même si on parle de
47000 le spectre et ceux qui se réduit
et qui tape ci sachant que c'est assez
alarmant parce que précisément on a dit
les grands partis de gouvernement la
droite et la gauche devrait avoir des
signatures sans aucun problème et
pourtant il ne représente plus beaucoup
de choses dans le poids locales par
exemple alors ils ont encore évidemment
des des élus locaux mais il y a en effet
une poussée vers la diversification des
partis que les maires eux-mêmes
représente finalement les conseils
municipaux sont aussi eux mêmes très
diversifié c'est bien triste d'entendre
que des mères qui viennent de différents
bords politiques ne savent pas
finalement ouvrir à la pluralité leur
signature néanmoins la question des
dépressions comme on l'a dit elle est
difficile à prouver mais elle est
insidieuse par un autre problème qu'il
faudra régler également dans ce
quinquennat qui à mon avis là la
réduction drastique des financements des
collectivités territoriales et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faudra poser à tête
reposée et je crois qu'en fait le vrai
problème qu'on rencontre pourquoi est-ce
qu'on se pose la question de ses 500
parrainages depuis 1962 c'est parce
qu'en réalité on nous dit quinze jours
avant l'élection qu'il faut les changer
mais évidemment ce n'est pas le moment
le conseil constitutionnel l'a même fait
savoir on ne change pas les règles du
jeu à deux semaines du jeu c'est ça
n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
constitutionnelle mais en plus de cela
pourquoi est-ce que lorsque les
majorités sont installés et que
justement il ya aussi une petite une
petite pointe que j'aimerais lancer on
dit souvent que c'est les partis
anti-système qui critiquent ces
parrainages mais est-ce que si eux
étaient au gouvernement il modifierait
cette loi ils le font savoir à l'heure
actuelle mais qu'en serait-il si il
était au pouvoir on peut savoir par
exemple que françois mitterrand était le
premier à critiquer la présidence
l'hyper présidence du général de gaulle
et qu'il a finalement bien bien utiliser
les habits d'hyperprésident quand il a
été président donc attention à cela on
ne peut pas changer la règle deux
semaines avant et je crois que
l'utiliser l'utilité de la critiquer
c'est de la faire changer quand on est
au pouvoir donc c'est vraiment ça qui
qu'il faut se poser comme question c'est
quel sera le bon moment pour réfléchir à
cette loi présidentielle et même aux
modalités du vote on en a parlé je pense
que c'est bien avant les scrutins qu'il
faudra poser sur la table cette question
la démocratie et de la et des articles 3
et 4 de notre constitution comment faire
c'est fonctionnement en début de
quinquennat le problème c'est que leur
débit quinquennat les majorités voudra
pas commencé par faire des grandes oies
sur notre petite cuisine interne et
d'autres crises électorales qui paraît
pas la cuisine
une chaussure les pressions dès que
subissent les élus qui auraient donné
des mauvais parrainage entre guillemets
qu'il se lève qu'il nous dise je
m'étonne que joueur on sort tout le
temps cet argument est que je ne vois
pas d'élu en france qui lève le doigt en
disant voilà ce que j'ai dit c'est
pression
on est quand même dans un monde où des
pressions politiques on en connaît et de
y compris dans les parties exercice aura
individuels et sociaux administrés et
vos projets se sont pas si ça se saurait
ça ce serait quelqu'un se lève et dise
j'ai été punie 15h10 j'ai été perdu mais
pourquoi aller donner - non attention on
va tâcher que dès que des maires il faut
rappeler que ce sont des élus willis
année et on rappelle que des lieux en a
donc ils sont 47 milles concernés merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat ici
sur ce plateau et en duplex évidemment
je vous dis à demain et je vous